[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime news
cast the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments this
past sunday we had our big discord party
to celebrate the fact that we now have
over 1,000 members on discord that was a
great time I had a lot of fun thank you
everyone who showed up and this coming
Friday you can finally look forward to
that big Q & A video it's going to be
dropping on Fridays so stay tuned for
that and here at anime upper we have a
whole bunch of new projects lined up and
coming in the near future including
videos on one punch man season two
Overlord season two seven deadly sin
season two and of course code geass
season three so stay tuned for that and
speaking of one punch man season two
Yusuke Murata who is one of the artists
on the jump version of one punch man
recently tweeted out that there will be
an update coming for one punch man on
May 11th so in only a few days we
already have official confirmation that
one punch man season 2 is in production
so could this new announcement have
something to do with an actual release
date for one punch man season 2 we're
not sure at this point but we will keep
you posted and if there is big news here
on this channel we will let you know
right away there will be a special video
so stay tuned for that in other news I
have to talk once again about the fake
news surrounding seven deadly sins
season two namely a publication called
stars Post recently came out with an
article claiming that a seven deadly
sins season three could potentially be
coming out in October of this year
that's right even though we still don't
have a seven deadly sin season 2 after
Netflix falsely promoted the four
episode TV special known as signs of a
holy war as 730 sin season 2 a bunch of
these fake news media have actually been
talking about a seven deadly sins season
three and even going so far as to say
that our release date for season three
might be sometime in October of 2017 now
of course this stuff is just nonsense
it's false information designed to get
you to click on their page because
you're surprised you're taking
in season two season three you click on
their page and then they get money from
their advertisers because of your clicks
however I'm surprised by how many people
actually believe this stuff I'm still
getting comments on my seven deadly sins
news videos saying cubed seven deadly
sins season two it's on Netflix when I
know that it isn't but it's mislabeled
and unfortunately people get confused so
I want to again stress to you guys there
is no official confirmation for a seven
deadly sin season two but we are
checking the official website the
official sources and as soon as we know
more we'll keep you posted this week our
board mahkumaat released part two of his
code geass season 3 legit theories video
and again like the first one this one
was hilarious it even featured some
memes from our discord server such as
body builder Nunnelly so if you haven't
seen it yet be sure to go and check it
out link is in the description and shout
out to Sirius and phantom H for the body
builder Nunnelly and while we're on the
topic of code geass this week pehle k
released a cover of colors by Flo the
first opening of Code Geass I'm a big
fan of pella case covers he always does
a great job and this time is no
exception I definitely encourage you to
check it out however I can't help but
think that maybe he was inspired by my
cover of the song that I sang only a
week earlier on one of our live streams
so I don't know let me know down in the
comments if you think that my amazing
singing influenced Bella Kaede to make
this cover Toni aka the black Critic guy
recently released a video on the top 10
weirdest anime in his opinion and even
though he didn't do a top 10 list in a
while I really enjoyed this one he
talked about some anime that I never
even heard of before and they were weird
as actual [ __ ] they were crazy so
definitely check out this video Tony
does a great job like always and I
learned some new stuff about anime that
I probably wish I never knew either way
it was a fun time check it out my
favorite a MV for this week with them
and we made by our boy D anime dude
which actually features a song made by
some of his friends the name of the song
is puzzled by a band called pseudo
why light and just overall I think the
anime do did a really good job on this
one it features a whole bunch of
different anime many of which I really
love so I definitely recommend this ambi
and yes I know what you're thinking man
Anna Mac you sure feature a lot of
people that you know and people who are
your friends on these weekly anime news
casts so we got black credit guy we have
the anime dude Mackel not pellet K I
mean come on
and well yes it's true that Pelican and
I are totally BFFs
I feature content that I'm exposed to
from channels that I subscribe to but
that is why I always say if you have
recommendations leave them in the
comments so if you want to recommend
some channels that I'm not exposed to
some youtubers that I don't know about
feel free to let me know down below and
that is it for this week guys if you
enjoyed these videos be sure to LIKE and
subscribe thanks so much to our patrons
for supporting the channel including
shadows a lovely tune that a gilgamesh
third strikes tomato christian floor or
bono forgotten not AKA girl bro and AMS
your support means a lot to us and until
next time sia space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]